ccsd board of trustees getting ready for
a very big meeting as two leaders may
have their jobs on the line one of them
president linda cavazos is speaking out
about the possibility of having her
title stripped from her 8 news now
reporter victoria saha joins us live
from where cavazos just held a press
conference victoria
board president linda cavazo stood her
ground trying to clear the air as to why
her name and title should not be on the
chopping block for tomorrow's meeting
two leaders of ccsd that could be
without a job a battle between the two
causing a division amongst the group on
one side you have president linda
cavazos and two other trustees wanting
to oust superintendent jesus jarrah and
then there are trustees who are wanting
to take president cavazos's title away
from her in wednesday's press conference
president cavazos addressed some of the
allegations toward her such as sending
emails to principals to gain support to
oust superintendent jara and creating a
toxic work environment for some of the
trustees i don't want anybody to accuse
me of you're trying to broker a deal in
a back room because that already happens
way too much trustee katie williams
alleges president cavazos bullies some
of the board members and causes a toxic
work environment she is one of the
trustees that requested to discuss
president cavazo's title i'm over it i'm
over her her tactics as a tyrant and
micromanager and things like that i'm
just i'm done with it because it's not
productive and it's not helpful williams
says ultimately she just wants everyone
to be able to work together she is
fearful if superintendent jara is
removed then the clark county school
district will run without a leader which
will ultimately affect staff and over
310 thousand students
now i did ask president cavazos about
those allegations of bullying and
toxic workplace environment she did deny
all that the trustee meeting will set
pla
set to take place excuse me tomorrow
evening at 5 pm there will be a vote as
to who is staying and who is going
victoria saha live local now